("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba mother fuckers.
I've been telling you.
- [Gary] There's so much good.
You know, one could argue
that they don't like fake news.
I could argue is the world
better of two or three old white
dudes dictate the
entire conversation in media
and where we go.
There's a pro
and con to all this.
All the people that find love
and great relationships that
never would've
because of this technology.
All the people that are on this
trip right now that can FaceTime
their family and have that
connection that we could've
never done before.
This is a net positive.
The world is never been better
yet we continue to
look at the negatives.
It's what happens, it's what
happens as we get older but the
technology changes in the
social changes have just begun.
The upside is an enormous.
Enormous.
One could say virtual reality
sounds scary and not fun.
I could argue like what's wrong
with living your life and then
living in a nicer place and
lowering the cost of where we
live because that becomes
commoditized and live healthier
and who's in be able to
balance getting off of it.
We're living in a
virtual reality world now.
There are people
that spend seven,
eight, 12, 13, 14 hours of
their day in the screen now.
This is the way it is and so
either we can cry about it and
put our head in the sand and
think it's a negative or we can
grab it and understand
all the great changes.
My brother left my business
because he has
Crohn's disease, right?
There's been no way that I
could impact the change of that
disease the way I am now
because of these devices and
technologies 10 or
15 or 20 years ago.
The impact was this big compared
in this big because of the
amplification and the messaging
that can be done and so you as
an individual person here are
gonna decide that all of this is
a negative or all
of this is a positive.
I've chosen this to
be a massive positive.
It is good.
There's so much opportunity.
There's so many great things
we're doing for so many people
and if you look at the
data, if you like data,
the world is better than it's
ever been across the board.
Right?
Now, what we have to do is make
this micro and bring it home.
I am so passionate for everybody
to understand that before you
critique or judge the
generations below you,
take a look under the
hood and really understand it.
Go look at studies like the
average 14-year-old girl
20 years ago claimed to
have 1.4 best friends
and now claims to have 6.
That because if you did have the
serendipity of being in a school
where people were nice to you
and maybe you didn't have any
outlet and you
were gonna get bullied,
you now can go online
and find your actual friends
and spend time with.
So I think we spend a lot of
time on the negatives and
we don't talk
about the positives.
What I would implore you to do
is think about the benefits of
positive versus negative.
I would implore you, especially
if you care if it's underneath
you, to start getting on the
offense around things like
self-esteem because that's where
it comes from instead of looking
at the other way.
- [Woman] (inaudible)
screen-free zone in your home.
- Yep.
- [Woman] Dinner,
everyone puts their device down.
- Yep.
- [Woman] Or couples,
a therapist would say,
put your phones down
and have one hour together.
- Yep.
- [Woman] Where you're
not looking at your phones.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] I'm sort of curious
about your family dynamic.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] Do you all have
phones at your dinner table?
- We run the, so couple things.
We run the gamut.
First and foremost,
I think we all know this.
There's a couple places,
I'm talking in general
terms if you've noticed.
Like, to me, the least
interesting thing in the world
is to tell people how to
parent their children, right?
I mean there's so many
individual contexts
here in this room.
Everybody's got
their own dynamics.
I think it's a lazy
and convenient thing.
Now, here's what I believe.
I believe, there's a
great Russian saying
so (speaking Russian).
I believe everything is
best when it's balanced.
Anything, you know, balance is
great but I also think you have
to understand so many variables
and I think that therapists if
you look at the history of the
feedback of therapists over the
last hundred years, the
consensus has been wrong plenty
of times because therapists are
collectively poor at predicting
what happens next
as are most people.
We make a lot of decisions
without understanding what
happens next and
so, you know, my family,
first of all, I'm a workaholic.
Monday through Friday
I barely see my family.
That's just true.
So on the weekends
it's extreme the other way.
We take seven weeks vacation
all-in phones locked up because
I'm playing such extremes.
I'm so politically not
correct on the current state of
parenting on just the framework
of where I am with them Monday
through Friday, let alone am
I sitting there with the phone
or not during
dinner time. Right?
Here's my big thing,
parents always think
they're protecting kids.
The amount of parents over the
last 20 years who took their
kids away from making
$15 million year being in an
e-sports superstar who is now
making $81,000 year in middle
management and wants to
kill himself is enormous.
(audience laughter)
So, what, you know,
there's been more parenting
books written in the last seven
years than prior of the
beginning of mankind to those
seven years ago.
America is very good at
one very interesting thing,
telling people and selling
on fear and telling them what
they're not good at.
And the current state of
parenting has completely gone
into that direction.
I've no interest
in the collective,
you know, current politically
correct POV on parenting.
What I'm interested in is
reverse engineering my kids.
I don't need them
to be entrepreneurs.
I don't care
what they want to do,
I just want to pay attention
to their behavior at scale and
reverse engineer that and
instill so much self-esteem into
them that they're borderline
delirious because that is the
drug that stops them from the
dumb shit that we all fear.
But no eighth place trophies
'cause that shit
has fucked us up.
(audience laughter and applause)
Thank you.
- [Woman 2] I have
a question for you.
Education--
- Education.
- [Woman 2] you're friends
with these guys who like
dropped out of college.
- Yeah, but a lot of my,
I was a bad student.
Let's remember the famous
dropped out of college 98% of
them, not me but 98% of them,
are dropping out of
Stanford and Harvard.
- [Woman 2] Right.
- You know, the whole dropped
out of college thing has been
very romanticized.
These are really
smart individuals.
- [Woman 2] So you still
value a formal education?
- I don't.
- [Woman 2] You don't?
- I do not.
I'm super comfortable,
so first of all,
I speak at all
these top universities.
I'm teaching a class
at Stanford this and that,
the lack of practicality that is
being taught in our universities
to the reality of
the world is staggering.
It's a bigger version of
what I said here with the kids,
what world do you think
that they're gonna live in?
Now, if you want to do a certain
profession I understand the
practicality of having to own
a diploma that
gives you the at-bat.
I spend a lot of my time in the
business entrepreneurial world,
there's zero mapping for that.
The MBA or the business
school mapping to the reality of
success has been completely
blown out the water and the
other thing that we don't talk
enough about his how this
debt destroys individuals.
They don't get it sometimes
until their 40s in a proper way.
- [Woman 2] Do you think these
online school programs will end
up replacing--
- So here's where we're going.
I think the thing that is
not been talked about that is
probably more interesting than
things I just said is colleges
are built on brand.
Like at their, the biggest
thing they're doing right now is
they're creating
these online courses that
are diluting their brand.
Penn and Stanford and Harvard
have these online courses and if
you look at the way the
people that are taking them are
positioning their certification
from these courses,
they're not
giving it the proper,
they're just
saying I went to Harvard.
And so, I think the biggest
universities in the world right
now for short-term income
because they're are getting
scale of $18,000 online courses
that are four weeks and they're
bringing in revenue are actually
diluting their brand so much and
I don't think that Harvard and
Stanford actually understand
that their only trading on brand
only 'cause the education has
been commoditized.
'Cause the professors have
that and they're putting out
their content online for free.
You can see it for free when
you're giving a TED talk or
doing four interviews
so the actual education,
the words what I did up
there, that's commoditized.
That's zero.
The only thing these big
universities are working on is
brand equity 'cause you grew
up believing in it so you're
forcing your
kids to believe in it.
That's very close to the
newspaper revenue model of
collapsing so I think they
only have 30 to 40 years left.
("Dreams" by Cartel)
I mean don't forget,
don't forget lost in history
is like when we definitely felt
like, you know,
what should to sell
Vayner for a million dollars?
We had that discussion.
You are out and
I was like I don't know.
(laughs) You know, it was there.
You know?
I wish fucking DailyVee was
there for that scene before that
speech at TechStars.
You know?
That'd be funny to look at.
So I mean, I think, you know,
I think there's a
million things to go through.
And we, it's always fun to, I
think this is a perfect example
of like not my
first rodeo, right?
Isn't it fun for you like have
all that context, right?
Mhmmm.
The ability for us
to do a commercial,
a two minute and now I'm also
creating this whole Facebook
commercial thing.
I think we're gonna be able to
do some really good deals where
(censored) Troy and he's doing
it for the seven location pizza
shop and we send Staphon and
make a two minute video for
Facebook that's why
they're gonna want to do it.
Every single day, people should
open the explore feature in
Twitter, look at the hashtags,
click the trending hashtags and
make a piece of
content that if this was,
if I had more time, I would be
doing that every two hours.
It is an absolute way
to build up on Twitter.
Nobody's really paying attention
as much to Twitter where it's
Instagram, Facebook and Snapchat
but just even looking at my own
dynamics when
I leverage a trending hashtag,
it's just exponential.
And I'm on this
real kick for this video.
This positivity video.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- This one.
When I think about our
capabilities to eliminate each
other, I'm being serious.
I know it kind of a
weird place to go but
the fact that we're still here.
We are hard wired in a way that
allows us to protect
each other in a net game.
Yet, the mainstream
media and the way we hear,
all you hear is negativity.
All that mainstream
media does this
tell us about the
.0001% worst of us.
I think we as humans are going
to have some level of a sense of
responsibility that
if you're a good place,
it might be good to Tweet or
Instagram or Snapchat about that
versus what we default into
which is there are people's
Twitter feeds that are basically
every seven or 10 days when
they're complaining about an
airline or venting about work.
Like the volume of negativity is
just way too high in reality of
what's going on.
Every empire falls when the
silent majority of happy isn't
loud enough and they
use the branding game.
Oh, we love the
third wall, DRock.
That third wall.
Yo, I just pulled up.
Where do I go?
Alright, right to the left here.
That first building?
Like right by the
baseball stadium sports complex.
Do I go towards
the the football field,
the field house?
Excited to go see
Alvin Kamara right now.
Beast, bunch of you watching
this right now he's about to be
your favorite football player.
So crazy to like
watch this in a year, right?
Good to see you.
- Yeah, dawg.
- [Gary] Who's this?
- [Alvin] Isiah.
- Isiah, what's
up, man? Gary.
- Isiah.
- Real pleasure.
How are you?
- Pretty good.
- Good, man.
- [Alvin] What's going on?
How'd the speaking thing--
- [Gary] Real good.
Real good.
How you feelin'?
It is, it is.
Look who it is, it is.
He's about to
roll up that way too.
(loud music)
Is there just a mix of
people working out here?
- [Alvin] Football right now.
- Very nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Real nice to meet you.
- Don't freak out.
- [Gary] No. I'm comfortable.
I love it, man.
I fucking love team sports, man.
- Yeah.
- Oh, God I wish I was
dramatically faster
and dramatically stronger.
I'd give up all
the business riches.
You know what it is?
The competition.
- Yeah.
- That's the reason
I love business so much.
'Cause I can replicate it a
little bit 'cause I'm trying to
put fuckin', I'm trying to put
people out of fucking business.
You know?
You were there
definitely when I was like,
"Listen to me mother fucker, you
can win or you're gonna lose."
- One or the other.
- That's the problem when
you're doing sports and music.
It's...
There's just not
a lot in the middle.
So what's on your mind?
What's important to you?
Anything?
Like how you thinking?
- All good. Working.
- Just focus on, right?
You still got a black,
can we change this logo?
- I don't know
what to change it to.
- [Gary] Your fucking face.
You got a pretty face.
Why you scared?
- I'm still in the basement.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm still in the basement.
- Change it to a Jets logo.
Change it to a Jets logo.
It's funny how
I feel about gyms now.
Now that I actually
work out I like it.
Ty, you can do some pull ups?
Show me.
Yeah, I want to
see your pull ups.
Two, good.
DRock, you can do pull ups?
I want to see
how many Ty can do.
That's six, that's good.
Let's go, Ty.
I'm impressed.
Get that tenth
baby, one more. Let's go.
That's gonna be some
good shit for the vlog.
- That's the first thing
I've done since fuckin'--
- Oh my God!
Alvin, Tyler should be dead.
Got hit by a car
in New York City. Hit.
Should be dead, straight up.
I'm dead fucking serious.
I got a good idea, I'm
gonna go Facebook Live,
I'm gonna make people try to
get Alvin go on their team.
(air siren wailing)
This alarm.
What is that?
- Fucking purge.
- Yo, yo, yo, Instagram.
Alright football fans,
it's time to plead your case
for the best running back
in the fucking draft.
Alvin.
- Damn right.
- Who wants Alvin
on their team? Show me.
Tell Alvin what team
he needs to be drafted by.
I'll start first.
The Jets.
Legendary's there, let's see.
One of you is
about to be real happy.
One of you is about to
buy a jersey of this man.
Ravens is first. Big fans.
Yes, mister.
- He got it.
- That was (laughs).
Let me save that one.
I think, by the way,
I think the Packers actually.
- (inaudible)
- Yeah, that
could be interesting.
(siren drowns
out all other sound)
- Seahawks.
Oh, Kevin Rose. K-Rose.
K-Rose, if you guys draft this
man it's gonna be the
greatest day of your life.
This guy's a super
star, Hall of Famer,
get ready. Tell 'em.
Guys, imagine if your career was
predicated on two random days in
Indianapolis where millions
of dollars are at stake for a
hundredth of a second.
- Running and jumping.
- K-Rose, imagine you have to
write code for an hour and that
predicted if you were gonna be
good or I had four minutes on
the liquor store floor
and however much wine I sold,
they predicted my
whole career on that.
Crazy. Anyway.
Alright fellas,
Alvin's got to get to work.
He's still in the dungeon.
That's why his
profile is still all black.
This guy. Alright,
talk to you guys later.
I was impressed
with those chin ups, Ty.
And they weren't
bullshit ones too.
You were trying
to do them proper.
- Come on.
- You know I'm starting
boxing in a year and a half.
- Year and a half?
- Yeah, when Jordan's done
I'm doing three years of boxing.
I'm gonna box every morning.
I'm gonna do boxing.
I'm gonna go in the ring
at 45 and knock DRock out.
- [DRock] Probably.
- [Gary] How do
you think about it?
- [Man] I always
dreamed to play football.
Shit, it's here now.
- [Gary] It's like
right there, right?
- [Man] Right.
You know, I started
playing when I was four.
- [Gary] And from the
get you were like this is
what I want to do.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man] Had a
gate about this high,
across the street from my
house and I was this tall.
I used to kick the
ball over the fence,
from a little
angle, kick the ball,
throw the ball.
- [Gary] Try to
jump over it, go get it.
- Yeah.
Everything and I mean
I was small back then.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- [Man] My mother
didn't trust the process.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- [Man] She used to tell me--
- [Gary] You gonna get hurt.
- [Man] yeah, basically.
- [Gary] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Man] So my grandmother,
she snuck me on the field when
dropped my mother off at work.
She like, he got those clothes
on and he bought that from
Walmart or something.
My mom would go to Walmart and
pick up the same clothes and
bring me to practice and change
me up back in those clothes.
- [Gary] I love that.
- She'll call you
and she'll be like,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] I know
exactly what,
you know it's so funny.
I was just reading about
that Uzi Barrett up in Philly.
Yeah, how his
mom wouldn't let him.
Like nobody believed in him.
His grandma got him
that Mike Jones album.
- [Man] Right.
- [Gary] And she's like,
"Keep going. Keep going."
You need somebody,
you got to have somebody.
- [Man] Right.
- [Gary] You know?
Yeah, I'm watching that too.
(wind drowns
out speaker)
12 month a year sport.
That's why these
kids play longer.
You know?
Gary.
- West Moss.
Big fan of yours, man.
- [Gary] Oh, thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] I appreciate the love.
- Thank you for
everything you do.
- [Gary] Thank you man.
- DRock.
- [Gary] (laughs)
You're on your shit.
- [West] How long
you in town for?
- [Gary] Oh, I just came to see
Alvin and I'm heading back to
New York in a second.
- In a bit?
- Yeah.
- Thanks for coming down.
- Of course.
- I'm the assistant
vice president here.
I oversee our academic units.
- Fantastic.
- So I saw you come in, I
thought I'd come by and say hi.
- I'm glad you did, my man.
- You need anything?
- No. I'm in great shape.
Thank you, real pleasure.
Thanks for saying hello.
- Thank you.
Can I get a picture with you?
- [Gary] Of course.
- Thanks man.
- Love it, man.
Thanks for the love.
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah, talk to you soon.
Continued success here.
That your iPhone?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there you go.
I'm gonna get to
225 eventually. (laughs)
- [Alvin] He'll fuck
around and test us like random.
We'll be in the
middle of workout,
he'll be like vert.
- [Gary] Really?
- [Alvin] Yeah.
You don't know when.
I won't get fucking used to,
it's just like the Combine,
that pressure.
When you all get there
it's not gonna be no pressure.
- [Gary] Well,
that's exactly right.
- [Alvin] Y'all ran through
it so many damn times.
- [Gary] Did you guys hear that
they're doing fans for the first
time but they can't say shit.
- [Alvin] Nuh-uh.
- [Gary] That should
be the weirdest shit.
There's gonna be like--
- [Alvin] That shit gonna be--
- there's gonna be a
1,000 fans watching but
they can't say a word.
- Fucking death penalty.
- Yeah, the whole
thing's so weird.
("Dreams" by Cartel)
A lot of times actually happen
in the comment section around
the creative where then we
can go in and business develop.
And we start with leverage
'cause it's people reaching out
to us that want
to be involved with.
This is an extraordinarily
big difference between the way
marketing has been done for
the last 70 years where we as
marketers and businesspeople sit
in a silo and try to create the
business development instead of
letting the lead creative become
the platform that creates
those opportunities and for my
personal brand and for the
startups I'm working with so
much of the extension of
campaigns have happened in the
comments section of
the creative once deployed.
("Dreams" by Cartel)
L.A. stand up. 6 P.M.
Wednesday, 15 of you, right?
'Cause I'm taking 10.
- Yep.
- [Gary] 15 of you are gonna be
part of something remarkable.
Intimate access.
I got to do this crazy fucking
thing and I'm gonna do a random
contest for 15 of you to come
and join and be a part of it so
Wednesday 6 P.M.
Fucking call out sick,
cancel your vacations,
lie to your mother.
Wednesday 6 P.M.
15 of you, I'll do something on
Monday or Tuesday in Instagram
as a contest and that's
how I'm gonna pick my 15.
See you then.
Wednesday 6 P.M.
next week Los Angeles.
- [Tyler] Boom.
- [Gary] Boom.
You got them working, Coach.
- What'd you think, man?
How'd he look?
- He (sighs),
he always looks good.
Just the way he talks about you.
I'm just so
thankful and grateful.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] I love
the way you do it.
I love, now that I'm learning
this game all these fancy guys
selling on bullshit.
- Oh my God. Yeah.
- [Gary] 90% bullshit.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Nothing that's
gonna make you real money,
real happiness on the field.
- Right, right.
- [Gary] So we
just appreciate it.
- Nah, definitely man.
- [Gary] He's a good kid.
- Yeah, good kid, man.
You know we're doing
some hard core stuff.
- I know you are.
You're doing him really right.
- Yeah. Really right.
- I appreciate it.
If I could ever
be a help to you,
let me know, okay?
- Okay.
- Thank you, my friend.
Al, I got to go.
- [Alvin] Alright.
- [Gary] I love you.
Hit me up (mumbles).
- [Alvin] Yeah.
- [Gary] Take care
of yourself, alright?
- You too.
- [Gary] Good
luck on everything.
- Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Hit me up
if you ever need me.
("Dreams" by Cartel)
Yes?
- [Man 2] Can I
ask for a selfie?
Huge fan.
- Is that right?
Yes, of course.
No problem.
- Thank you very much.
It was a big
pleasure to be your driver.
- Thank you very much, man.
Transforming into airport Gary.
Look at that guy's kicks. Legit.
I can do it, a selfie.
Thank you very much.
- My pleasure.
Thank you, my friend.
- All the best.
- [Gary] Thank you, thank you.
- [Man 2] Bye-bye.
- It's warm out.
This is how Tamara Vaynerchuk
taught me how to pack.
Thanks mom for
packing me all the time.
Airport Gary, what?
I thought you said phone call.
I'm so wired for action.
I'm like, "Phone call, what?"
Mother fucker.
Alright, get me the video.
Yeah, great week.
Actually fairly rest week.
You know?
You know what's so weird?
This was such a rest week
yet I was like tired because,
I was tired
because it was a rest,
it wasn't that late every day.
Oh, people are going to love
the video of my sleeping.
That's gonna go bat shit crazy.
Red eye time
for me and DRock.
And that dude, right there.
Just looked.